let's be clear abortion bans increase both the maternity mortality rate
and the infant mortality rate
and they do that without even meeting their purported policy end goal
which is to decrease the number of abortions
none of this is new research
like decades of research across culture
geography and time have demonstrated the same thing
Republicans know this and they don't care
because it's not actually about reducing the abortion rate
if it was
you would do meaningful things that actually do meet that policy and goal
like education and access to contraception
both of which they are also actively attacking
they claim to be very haunted by abortions that occur later in a pregnancy
yet they are completely responsible for putting in all of the restrictions
that delay women's access to getting an abortion earlier in her pregnancy
like imposing literal waiting periods or requiring multiple in person
unnecessary appointments again
it's not about saving babies
saving children women's healthcare
any of that it's about controlling women
it's about controlling reproduction and sustaining a patriarchy
and punishing women who freely engage in their own pleasure
yes I am wearing an a for abortion
vote like your life depends on it
because for many of us it literally does